(whoosh, creak)
- An existential haunting?
That's very weird, I would not think of
a haunted experience and existential
in the same breath.
Does that mean it's gonna,
change me?
- I mean, I read a couple things online
from people who've wrote articles
about their experience,
but it never really
went into detail, so
I'm kind of in the dark
on this one.
- Yeah, maybe literally in the dark
later tonight, we'll see.
- Having done this before,
I find it is scary,
but the more I do it,
the more excited I am,
the more I realize this
is more about wonderment.
- It's all about getting inside your head
and freaking you out on this deeper level,
which is what I'm really excited about.
- I don't know if I like that.
That's a little creepy.
- We see people coming out,
like a rollercoaster.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Sometimes you see them all messed up,
and you're like, "Uh oh."
- I don't really know
what to expect with this.
- I'm scared, I'm gonna lie.
I'm a little scared.
I don't know what they're gonna do to me.
Hopefully I'm here tomorrow.
(low, haunting music)
(dramatic music)
- What the hell just happened?
- That was really cool,
but it was really weird.
I donno, it was...
- Uh, I just walked out of there.
It was a little bit more, like, erotic
than I was expecting.
- Every room, I was confused
and just disoriented.
It played on your, I guess, basic fears.
- I never really knew what was going on,
but it was really fun.
- No one really jumped out at you,
they more just like, grabbed on to you
and guided you through this crazy
mental experience.
- It was really rad.
I would definitely do it again.
- It was like I was tripping.
Like stoned or something.
- I know, I'm like,
"Can I drive home now?"
Am I okay?
Am I under the influence?